hello everybody welcome back to the
chord or digital podcast episode 129.
we've got a great show for you today um
we've got sam and nico and myself jake
and before we kick this off i'm gonna
play the same exact song that i played
last week for nico and we're gonna see
if he can recognize what it is are you
ready i'm ready
all right
play along at home
play along at home if you know what this
is it's a classic
[Music]
last time i had to get to the hook the
that's that 180 song
ac dc
oh yeah
yep
chick you've been picking up your cover
game
[Music]
acoustic covers by jake covers by jake
next week we got weasel this song
by weezer
and then blackbird by the beatles
wait this is weezy right this is weezer
yeah okay
okay yeah cool
well what's up this week other than all
the crap
yeah yeah other than the war that's
going on yeah good old war yeah i um you
can take people's minds off of it and
talk about cool things happening yeah
i think cool things happening i don't
really want to talk i'm down to talk
about that just i don't want to talk
about it right now
what corridor
no the war
oh yeah no i think uh i think there's
just a couple dudes doing vfx
yeah we're good on not not dealing too
deep into geography just just just know
we're aware
we'll get there we'll get there it'll
slip through the cracks yeah i'm sure it
will i'm sure it will um so anyways hey
what else is going on i did that i did
learn how to do a kung fu fight last
week sorry karate fight karate yeah i
did a karate fight uh currently working
on some vfx for a scott atkins movie
yep um that's
super cool stuff going on yeah that's
that's what i got going on yeah and all
i'm doing is just a continuation from
what we talked about on the last podcast
we are we are moving forward with the uh
virtual influencer idea it sounds yeah
i'm messing with that i have to learn
python like nico did basically but i got
to like learn my own version because
it's a whole different thing
but it's really cool it's working so far
like i'm generating scripts that like i
have moods and dance moves listed in the
dialogue
i don't want to spoil anything but i had
to drop a brand integration into the
project folder and i noticed that there
was a file
with a date on it that said jake's voice
working
so i don't yeah no i'm doing i'm doing
uh i'm doing that for everyone right now
i got one for me
i have one for ren i'm working on one
for you
i'm just testing the waters here a
little bit with uh
um yeah like
who's like yeah basically just kind of
getting voice sets we talked about this
last time with like you know all the
hours we have on the podcast it's like
the perfect
spot
to like start trying to train stuff so
yeah
but yeah don't open anything in case
there's surprises i didn't i didn't i i
okay i just my eyes couldn't avoid
seeing that title and so oh yeah you see
your name and you're like oh no
yeah exactly well but
i kind of
knew that part of the strategy was to
see if we could create a digi double of
me
so yeah i mean that that's on that's on
the to-do list
but you know we'll we're we'll we'll get
there
okay you're using gpt-3
to write scripts for the scripts though
yeah the script stuff is the gpg3 stuff
yeah
i did a little ai experiment last week
but it didn't work out
[Laughter]
well nvidia released the thing that's uh
so
neural
something radiance fields like some i
can't quite remember the exact term but
it's called nerfs
basically imagine like you've seen like
volumetric things before like fire smoke
or vfx
so you can do volumetric shapes also and
they have uh ai algorithms that can just
take pictures and basically like do the
equivalent of a photo scan but it makes
a volumetric reproduction
of your of whatever it is that you're
doing uh which is super cool because you
don't need as many pictures as you would
for like rebuilding something in 3d
um and it's also not like a meshed
object it's like almost like colored
clouds and like the more the better it
is the more hyper detailed that cloud
becomes to where it looks like it's
actually the shape
um and nvidia came out with a thing that
makes like 30 times faster the point
where you can
basically generate it in a matter of
seconds so imagine like photo scanning
just like snapping your fingers and it's
ready um which is super cool but
every time i run it it gets like halfway
through it and then it just crashes um
it's just one of those things like the
program keeps running and it's crashing
internally so like something inside the
program is breaking somewhere and
trying to get it running was very very
difficult and trying to get running in
linux would be the next step and i don't
know if i got the wherewithal to do that
so
yeah there's always like when like when
something stop isn't working and you're
solving bugs there's a certain point we
start stressing out because you're like
i really should be doing something else
with my time like researching the next
vfx artist react episode
or something yeah yeah that stuff's
crazy like when i think about like the
problems that like autonomous vehicles
have um you know you know it's like you
have a car that has like they're using
cameras and lidar on tesla's for that
stuff yeah but effectively it's like 2d
image recognition it seems like yeah
because they backed off the lidar things
they couldn't get parts for them
it's crazy during the supply chain
crisis that's crazy but like thinking
about that kind of stuff of like all
right here's like a few images it's like
okay
you want a card to do image recognition
how much better would it be if it had
something 3d to work with yeah and so
even though the camera's not you know
maybe you would have two cameras
or even just one because the car is in
movement you know yeah i mean i would
argue that if you have a self-driving
car you should have something better
than cameras like human beings have
eyeballs we get into car accidents
pretty frequently like let's let's i've
got the next best thing yeah you know
give me a lighter and cameras
um but ren noticed that like his tesla
doesn't have lidar in it because it's
from the era right now whether it
doesn't the lidar wasn't available
what a piece of junk
he does notice that it doesn't slide up
as quickly it's like it's it's not quite
as uh
forward-looking as like a lidar equipped
to tesla is but i'll bet that at some
point in the future
they retrofit these cars with lidar
he knows he can just use his foot right
right yeah i mean mine doesn't have a
little speaker like all tesla's now like
when they're backing up and mine doesn't
do it because i don't have a speaker
installed
because before the regulation passed
dude what was the regulator they have to
have speakers yeah so electric cars have
to have speakers in them because they
have to make a noise when they're
backing up which makes sense
and there's also uh i believe they have
to make a noise when if they do uh an
emergency stop because they detect a
pedestrian when they make a noise inside
to alert the driver they need to make
the same noise outside to alert the
pedestrian
that sounds like a california law is
that a national thing mm-hmm yeah this
is what that makes that makes sense
though yeah it makes sense and the cow's
going look i'm gonna hit you like it's
kind of nice for it to say something
outwards as well as yeah
i mean i'm not i'm not against it i'm
just saying alert there's no statement
no loves being first on like those kinds
of laws than california california it's
a natural thing actually it's uh it's a
national
they've been making rules uh it was the
electronic mustang actually that kicked
a lot of these into effect okay okay
yeah funny i like the sounds that
electric cars make yeah and they go by
and they go like they have those like
some what is it kias make it like a cord
it's like they have this like soft
subtle like chorus synthesizer pad
sound and like like
it's kind of it's kind of pleasing
there's vanity engine noises that's
going to be a thing yeah do you think
yeah exactly
do you think in the future like you can
sync up with the other cars around you
and all the cars that are traveling in a
bunch can like play a song oh man well
they all just play like one note you
send it but it makes a chord you set the
uh yeah you set the frequency of the
note to the speed of the car so like as
like you're in traffic you can just get
like all these different chords as
people accelerate and decelerate
that would sound amazing yeah that
probably that would be kind of cool
that'd bring world peace probably
yeah there we go see i solved
solved it wait tesla's never got to have
vanity engine noises like because ren
has one that
plays like a witcher song or something
yeah no he honks the horn and it goes
like i did according to your witcher
dude
and i'm like what like sweet that's
using that speaker the alert speaker for
that because you can also talk through
your phone and have it go like citizen
step away from my car step away
deploying toxic gas well it filters your
voice too it makes you sound like a
freaking combine from half-life that's
sweet it's super sweet that's like
really cool my car doesn't have a
speaker so i can't do it you can't do
any of this cool stuff
nope
yeah you guys play music you're missing
out man just tape a bluetooth speaker to
the hood yeah
i had to get i had to get out of
wendy and i got a suburban because uh we
have six people in our family and um
like
it's not even a new one it's a 2017.
it's it's like a nice car but it's like
i had to get out of it the other day
because i was just like you know what
i'm done
i'm done with this car i don't know how
they make them this nice anymore you
know how i i just became completely
discouraged by like
how much work you'd have to do to like
make something equivalent to that
and teslas are like a whole nother level
up but like everything from like the
stitching on the dashboard and how it's
like perfectly machined you know oh you
didn't oh you didn't get out of a lease
you meant like step outside of the
vehicle no i had to like leave the
vehicle yeah
it wasn't a bad thing it wasn't like you
had to return it okay no no okay yeah
sorry it sounded kind of bad at first
yeah no it's crazy how much like
iteration has like iterations become a
thing over the past like 20 to 30 years
and now we're looking at these products
that are so hyper refined that like you
just you can't get in there without
doing so
they're so crazy
like i don't think people quite
appreciate it like just how
ridiculously
difficult and like
and to still make it profitable
yeah and to like yeah and all the
iteration and infrastructure and capital
that's required to like we're going to
make a car
we're going to you know yeah
i saw a really great video i can't
remember i think this is maybe like
three or four years back but it was a
guy who was like i'm gonna make um
iphone from scratch oh yeah from
stranger parts oh yeah yeah so he just
basically hops around shenzhen or
whatever for
like a month or something basically
collecting stuff and doing
you know tests on it and is it youtube
eventually
yeah strange parts is what it's called
yeah yeah and then he finds like a
knockoff iphone case yeah to like put
all the parts inside of yeah it's really
crazy because he basically just found
all like the chip sets uh you can just
get in shenzhen which is really cool
yeah yeah
and jake jake's gone
sorry i'm back i was just adjusting my
focus i could hear you guys the whole
time but yeah i know it's it's it's
fascinating and really yeah really
difficult was he able to make it mm-hmm
yeah yeah he ended up with an iphone
it's a how did he did he program the os
himself
no i just installed ios
oh okay so he made the heart he put all
the hardware together right right right
yeah he basically did like so when you
have an iphone you pop it open there's
like there's this brace there's this
chip set there's this circuit board and
he basically just parted out all the
pieces and went to all the individual
suppliers
basically at a mall effectively and
walked in the store like i'll buy that
chipset and i'll buy that you know
circuit board and i'll buy that little
like brace and i'll buy that battery and
put it all together it's really crazy
and it shows you how much
nuance there is in manufacturing and
how little of that is happening over in
the united states right now in terms of
like industry like there's some of it
happening but you can't just go to like
an electronics
strip mall and
piece out the pieces that you or price
out the pieces that you need to build
your electronics project or whatever it
is yeah that doesn't exist but you're
also talking about shenzhen like
literally that is like the
i mean there's a reason why it's right
across from hong kong and like it is
what it is because
they were like hey we're gonna build
this stuff and then it was like western
money
and
and like distribution
into hong kong and then they're like
well let's put the factories
right here
you know we're supposed to say i mean
is the electronics capital of the world
it like that is the pinnacle of
mankind's computer engineering
yeah you're absolutely right that like
it is
going on
such at such it's it's almost an
uncomparably more so
a rate of of of of that happening over
there um do you guys speaking of phones
you guys remember the bat phones
yeah the headphones the bat phones yeah
i think
i think it was yeah that's funny that's
a story there
i mean it's probably come up time and
time again here but i don't think we've
talked about when they were they rolled
over to the smaller sim cards
eventually i don't i don't know yeah and
when they rolled over to the smaller sim
cards that one those ones stopped
working eventually yeah yeah so like
years ago in 2014 we shot this thing
called snapper hero which was like this
wacky snapchat series
that we got roped into and it was fun it
was fun film it was great meeting all
the people filming it
a snapchat series yeah it's kind of the
first one's kind actually the first
narrative snapchat series where 24 each
episode only lived for 24 hours and they
were gone forever
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so we have a little trophy that
says we did it
um
because you can't prove it because we
can't prove it yeah yeah we did win four
streamies that year
oh yeah that was a good one
uh but basically uh so
um
for the shoot i think it was like a t
sponsored part of it or whatever so
basically we got a ton of phones from
them it was like a bucket it was like 12
or 15
samsung galaxy
sevens yeah note sevens yeah yeah so
they're yeah they were notes
they're decent hardware and so we're
obviously using them for like all the
props it's funny we filmed the whole
thing on iphones because we require like
the better camera and
there's more filming and video apps that
we could use to actually you know make
the piece but then we pretended like
everyone was using these samsung phones
and the best thing about the phones is
that they're all actually functional
phones with sim cards and they're all
activated with unlimited data plans
and so when the shoot was done
well
the phones began to disappear very
quickly
and i don't remember
exactly what was going on but it was
like oh wait a second like where did
like half of these phones go
and so we started playing with them and
we're like wait a second they're all
still activated
like what's going on they all have data
plans they all have functioning phone
numbers they all work as mobile hot
spots they'll work as mobile spots and
so then we just split them up and we all
have these bat phones which basically
we're using constantly for
like hot spots because this is the day
when you had a cap on your internet like
we literally had
what was like 10 no we had five
gigabytes uh that like we shared in the
family plans yeah we were sharing we
still share that
yeah yeah
now it's unlimited though
yeah yeah but back then they didn't have
unlimited there used to be like the true
unlimited that people are grandfathered
into which sam had for a while actually
on his iphone yep but you know data caps
right and we're all trying to deal with
that so we call them the bat phones
because it's like batman's phone as in
it's an untrackable
corporate activated phone with unlimited
data
so like any time we went on a trip
anywhere we would just like throw it in
the car throw it in our pocket and then
we'd turn it on and then anybody in the
car could have wi-fi for the entire road
trip yeah yeah and you could watch
netflix listen to music you do whatever
and you never hit your data caps i
brought one overseas i can't remember
where i think i brought one uh iceland
did it work yeah it was working i just
had international data yeah so i just
was doing roaming streaming and
everything yeah
it was great
yeah full corporate activated phones
and then i remember we went to uh we
went to detroit to film our battlefield
series and we were in this hotel you
know it was like a cheap hotel extended
state place and they had wi-fi but like
you know they have like one router in
the center of the area so like
everyone's just on the crappiest
internet connection and of course i have
my bat phone so i could watch netflix i
could watch youtube because you couldn't
watch it otherwise they didn't have like
wi-fi you could access in your room and
i went through 60 gigabytes of data on
that phone over the 49 days that we were
out there yeah
and just to put it out there like five
gigabytes or 10 gigabytes like our total
data plan like for our entire family
sharing i went through 60.
that was pretty great it was wonderful
yeah
you know anytime anywhere you went you
just always had internet and there's
unlimited
and then then 2020 rolled around 2008
yeah somebody shut it down someone's
like hey can someone audit like all the
free phones that are out there and i
have a feeling they did nodded it i have
a feeling they just punched in the date
and they just put 2020 as like the
like turns off yeah yeah i think they
just probably had an automatic
protocol that would have the effect oh
yeah yeah this guy's only
i know i think they just cleaned house
they probably were like hey hit the red
button they hit it and like all the
phones get deactivated like all right uh
so who which ones do we need on
yeah just delete all the phone numbers
that haven't been used in the past year
and if they need it they can call us
so i found
uh somebody has re-uploaded uh episodes
of snapperhero
to youtube yeah but not all of them no
not all of them i i don't think they
yeah and the reason we didn't upload
them to youtube was because
at the time
youtube didn't support
aspect ratios as like a concept it was
like it was 69 video
anything that could fit inside of it you
know you couldn't even upload 21.9 stuff
and have it played properly in a player
yet
yeah and so we're like sitting there
going like this is gonna be really weird
to upload a whole series of vertical
video
with like
side to side chunky letterboxing
is 21.9 even is 21.9 even supported
today yeah you can finally add
okay
wait no this guy's there oh wait no it
only starts an episode all right so
here's here here are the comments
there's only two comments
somebody says where are episodes one
through three and then another person
says i refuse to believe that chord or
digital had anything to do with this
and then the guy who the guy who
uploaded it says believe it or not it's
true it may it's made like this on
purpose so it seems like it has been
completely edited on mobile phones via
snapchat i'm just
registrating episodes
registrating and importing here
and porting here to youtube so people
can watch here too
right who's registrating
dude the old registrator
dude my favorite joke though my favorite
joke from that series which i i think
it's only sam and i find it funny but i
start crying when i think about it i'm
so funny so freddie dies uh in the
snapper hero like straight up dies he
falls through his death harley kills him
and
his shonduras's power
is that whatever he draws comes to life
so he's like all right i've been
practicing and practicing and practicing
drawing on snapchats remember you could
draw on snapchat back and forth using
like a stylus and a tiny screen and like
a selection of 12 colors and i'm going
to draw freddy and bring him back to
life and so he tries it and it's just
like this random asian guy that we got
from like a local casting yeah he's not
a good actor like you know what
community channel like community access
tv channel like style like actor he's
like i'm back
everybody act like he's freddy so they
all like
[Music]
[Laughter]
just leave it and like the extra funny
things like you have all these
influencers like all these big youtube
and snapchat and viners at the time
jumping around like hugging this one
random like dentist from like encino
it's like you're back freddy
so
yeah that was a good one
oh man snap snapchat got pissed at us
because
they had they were just launching their
like news and like curated channels they
didn't have curated channels when we
started the show and then we dropped to
the show and about halfway through is
when they launched their curated like
news channels which is all they're all
garbage at the time
and like we were kind of the first ones
that were doing this curated like like
actual produced narrative on snapchat
and the the headquarters did not like it
and in fact there were back doors for
uploading to snapchat just like video
clips which is what we did for the first
like eight episodes yeah basically it
was uh it was it was like a jailbroken
app yeah you used the job they were
using to
get them uploaded onto this account and
they were truly hacking it yeah yeah and
then snapchat's like you guys need to
start you guys can't do that anymore you
like you can't upload backdoor to our
snapchat app we're first we're going to
block you from doing that secondly if
you do it again if you figure out
another way we will delete your channel
from snapchat
because you aren't you aren't playing by
the rules you uploaded a video without
having it just be a natural video so
then we set up a little system
to record the screen of an ipad with the
screen with the camera on the phone
and this nick laurent ran this
and you just had to record it's
literally like doing a cam rip in a
theater where like you go in with a
video camera and you record the screen
and just whatever audio the camera's
microphone picks up is what you get so
there's this weird shift part way
through snapper hero where like it just
switches over to like being filmed off
of a screen
because he can't upload natively uh
man god what big tech what a bunch of
[ __ ]
what the hell was going on
then
like we we so at t was like hey we want
you guys to do this series
and then
no consultation was done with
anyone from snapchat
well we didn't need to yeah because it
was just like well we have a way to do
and it works this is harmlessly
uploading silly video clips
right
but snapchat i was like number one
snapchatter at the time yeah so
now because that was the like that was
the uh
like that was the era where all these
like social media platforms had that
decide if they're going to try to take a
cut
of people like selling their own brand
integrations right you know because like
on youtube youtube sells ads and you get
a cut of the ads and youtube gets more
of a cut of the ads you know but if i
sell effectively the exact same thing
except instead of going through
youtube's pre-roll system they just come
to us directly which is basically what
you see on every episode of visual
effects artists react thanks to
christian
uh you you're seeing us skipping the
youtube system you know right it's like
it's like it's like calling an uber
driver and he pulls up he goes cancel
the ride and just pay me directly you
know and then like i'll give you a
little discount and i'll make more money
and like so there's a moment in time
when
you know all these different platforms
were like all right we're going to get a
cut of that and like youtube started to
do it just barely
and then i don't know what it was
somebody was smart and they had a good
head on their shoulders they went no no
no don't do this on youtube it's going
to be a can of worms for us and so
youtube backed off and it's never been
an issue but snapchat however because
they had a it's because they had adsense
yeah so they have adsense and i think
they also realize that they would
basically
like if they got too involved suddenly
now they're taking on
way too much responsibility every single
brand integration becomes like well
youtube if you're getting a cut now it's
your problem if i have a problem you
know it's like they didn't want to be a
part of all that you know it's like
we're just going to stand back here you
guys are your thing but snapchat however
did not feel the same way and they're
like oh if you're doing a big brand
integration on snapchat and you're
making money by broadcasting on our
platform i think we need to cut
which is also so weird like you think
about these are like you know billion
dollar companies they're like i need 10
you know 30 000 for you to run your
thing
the thing was is that i don't they were
pre money though that's technically yeah
you know it's and i don't i don't know
does snapchat i i know nothing about
snapchat by the way so don't don't
crucify me in the comments but like does
snapchat even have a monetization system
probably for like 10 people or whatever
probably about as much of a monetization
system as twitter does videos on yeah
monetizing your tweets
i mean
twitter has a more formalized
monetization system now with video
[Music]
how to make money on snapchat
but why can't you monetize like poems on
twitter
i
i just made
ten thousand dollars
twelve ways to make money on snapchat
here we go are you guys ready
[Music]
promote products yeah
no crap like 18 t
create snapchat ads with a high
click-through rate snapchat is a popular
social media site for advertising as a
small business
money that's how you spend money
this is a bs article that has not been
written by a human being by the way jake
this format every single article now
anytime i google a question
this is the articles that pop up where
it's just a type
like a numbered list that goes through a
bunch of questions and it doesn't
actually answer the question you want
it's just a bunch of fluff do a story on
this
works now
well i just i mean i'm sure there's
other do you want me to pick a more like
educational one this one's
you mentioned the selling product thing
that does remind me
so this is here this is a series that
corridor digital is shooting right and
so me and sam are like it's all our
buddies that we're shooting with plus a
few other people that we got to meet and
sound like well we should be in at least
one episode
you know we should have some funny
characters we get to play and so we play
these construction workers that are up
on this roof that are noticing like
freddy's learning to fly and there's
like a fight scene going on with harley
so you have a really funny scene that we
shoot oh man we have like reflective
vests and hard hats on
anyways 18t is like cut the scene you
guys can cut the scene like what's wrong
it's like your helmets are blue
they almost are blue
oh yeah we wore blue helmets and that
implied that we were working with a t
and t
or like we were at t employees they
might think you're a t employees
therefore you have to remove your entire
scene from this they're like what if we
just change the color of our helmets
they're like no cut the scene
and change the color
yeah whatever exactly you can do
like [ __ ] you
sorry but [ __ ] you yeah
like you do your job and that's not
doing it i i think the article you read
is an ai article dude every article in
the article
i was just asking my ai friend to do for
the same thing for twitter how to make
money on twitter use twitter to connect
with potential customers and followers
share your helpful and interesting
content that is relevant here we go here
we go uh snapchat doesn't this is as of
2021 snapchat does not include any ads
that you use to earn money like youtube
so you need to promote a product or
service oh look at that god they're
trying to figure it out
[ __ ] miserable how long has this
platform been around and they haven't
figured out a way to monetize it
well god forbid you use social media for
how is this a publicly no i understand
that but like how is this a publicly
traded
where's the value it's not even like
trump's on snapchat how is it a
fundamental
this is not how is this a fundamental
value stock in any way
it's trading at
37.84 that's ridiculous i think they're
just you know absorbing all the
children's data and then yeah they're
just like marketing caps
and a half billion
well it's like it's like google you know
you know you just harvest the children's
data and then sell it to advertisers
harvest the children's data
yes
for real
that's that's it that's true yeah
god that's so messed up man
tick tock is the king of that
the the the reaper of of data it is the
reaper of data dude the government
really needs to get on top of that no
one has any idea what to do right now
but
soon hopefully bad dude tick tock is
literally just all of them all of them
are so bad
yeah that is hardest data the easiest
way to harvest data is to use a data
scraping tool
okay
tick-tock is is
it's it's shady as hell
like i i yeah let me just see if i can
pull up some some quick some quick i'm
sure there's plenty of articles that
talk about how shady it is man yeah
there's a million articles yeah
what other fun things are in april 2020
tick tock officially cooperated with
mainland china's internet censorship
mechanism and began to prohibit the use
of overseas versions of do you and which
is tick tock in mainland china
they also do things like
actively
decrease viewership on people that are
considered like undesirable
like okay whether that's like yeah it's
like real
well real bad guys we just finally hit
our segway here yeah we are geopolitics
all right so earlier this year
russia was like hey
russia was like hey google if you don't
censor the crap we want you to censor
we're gonna physically close your
offices oh really in moscow we will
physically go there and jack you up and
arrest you and close your stuff if you
don't
start listening to us as far as like get
we want control we want this we want xyz
we want to control the start
for what platform for google exactly
okay this this straight up happened fact
check me
or not basically
basically so they do this earlier this
year okay and like well what does that
do well what is it basically you know
it's preventing
you know global communication from
reaching russians you know a large
portion of it anyways um now you know we
see the last week here okay so what's
happening well you know russia goes
ding-dong
kicks the door open ukraine blah blah
blah
shoot some bombs
well look
i'm not gonna
look i don't want to get too deep into
the war war war part of it right right
because it's obviously [ __ ] up and
obviously russia has been like the
classic enemy for the last 60 years so i
don't need to like say uh condemn russia
it's like
we do we do decades of condemnation all
right i've got decades to back me up
anyways the point is
i'm tracking where you're at i found
some articles yeah so so so you know
they're doing this and then the last you
know
week it's like okay so what do we do
what do you do when a big big baddie
does some bad stuff and right now it's
like okay well you can donate you can
send ammo i guess everyone's just you
know it's like but effectively it's like
sports you know we see there's team in
russia and there's team ukraine and
everyone is picking a side
and then buying a t-shirt
uh depending on their team you know some
people buy ukraine shirts and well we
cheer you know it's like
come on ukraine come on ukraine
we're not getting onto the sports field
we're not like tossing balls down
like barely
met very few people are even like
bringing water to the sidelines you know
what i'm saying
and yeah because it can very easily any
any action in that regard could very
easily be seen as an act of war oh
absolutely by yeah this is very is a
very tenuous
situation it is it is and i'm not going
to say people aren't just yeah i'm not
going to say it isn't but
where i'm getting at is
like
the strategy is all right you know get
to russia from the inside you know we
close access to international like bank
transfers through like swift
uh that's happening you know there's
other sanctions happening here and there
blah blah and ultimately it's it's like
yeah what can you do well the only thing
you can do in that situation is hope
that people in russia
don't want to put up with this and
they're like
and that seems to be certainly a large
sentiment like i've seen russian
youtubers saying
this is stupid yeah we really really
don't want to do it also i can't i can't
really go into detail about how i feel
about this but all i'm saying is do i
like it or not i don't like it and they
can't go into detail because
my state might might assassinate me or
make me exactly and well that's true and
they're you know but they're putting
this on youtube and it's not even
assassination or jail but it's also
because like you know russia as i said
they now they have control over these
platforms and so
you know you look at that situation of
like well how are they going to do it
from the inside i guess they have to be
aware of what's happening
and how are they going to be made aware
you know like there's there's there's
means there's firewalls you can you know
you can subvert with vpns in fact it's
super common i was talking i was talking
to a guy who lives in freaking
i don't know somewhere in the middle oh
i ran on instagram i'm like what's going
on he's like sup i live and i ran like
you're using a vpn right so yeah it goes
through amsterdam
you know and i'm like okay so so that
it's a thing you know in these countries
but ultimately you know
if you want that kind of communication
to happen within a country you can't be
like
i don't know it just
it feels like
if you okay what are the options well
bring water to the sidelines bring other
countries
weapons and ammunition or
hope that they can communicate and if
you don't do either it's like yeah it's
like what what's happening like
we google and like all these big tech
companies are like letting
these these dictatorships push them
around and now in a time where
that would be really useful
and allow these people in this country
to actually formulate decisions for
themselves
uh you know it's not available yeah and
and now now we get now we get to see
what the effect is you know or or start
to see those effects
of uh what feel like kind of small
um what's it when you kind of give
something up yeah you know consensus
concessions it feels like small
concessions until now when you're like
oh i really wish
they could like the majority of people
in this country could get a full a
better picture on what's happening yeah
i mean russia could always just knock
out the connection entirely
you know with those kind of things but i
totally get what you're saying and i i
feel this i feel somewhere what you're
saying is that like
a company like google when a company
like or in a country like russia or
china's goes you know hey you need to
follow our laws i get that i get
following another country's laws and
making sure you operate within you know
their legal framework and what they do
but on the flip side
they're definitely using that moral code
and they're like we need to censor
information at a certain point as a
company and you go like you know what
i'm okay not making that much money that
i could make if i was here i'm gonna
remove my product entirely and you guys
have to match your own version yeah
yeah don't give them
that's got to be the line like
because what else do you do you just
capitulate and then you create a you
create a superior product in general to
the one that's actual and yeah and out
there but then and then b you you know
you're
you're supporting tyranny yeah and yeah
it's like and so what and so what so you
can make money so now you're making
money from it it's like that's that's
even more disgusting that's evil that's
straight up evil yeah i know it's like
we're not we still have our own morals
uh and it's just you know we're you know
changing some stuff to find this other
country when you're in russia yeah i
just you know like look i yeah i joined
this club where we shoot innocent people
but like that's not like my morals like
my morals is to not shoot innocent
people but when i'm here in this one
specific spot we do that just because
it's a local tradition
it's like
oh right okay so but those become your
morals now because you're doing it yeah
and you you're supporting it and so you
know like the argument the big argument
against that is well if we do that then
they'll just make their own it's like
good let them make it
that's what china did you know like
weibo or wechat and at least if they go
hey i'm going to google it they're going
to get an actual functioning version of
google if they use a vpn rather than
never knowing that google actually
doesn't censor your results it's like
yeah force them to make their own go out
there and have them do the work right
what does that do for the integrity of
the product in the region or country
where it originated
like it it makes you question whether or
not the results that you're getting
are
are unbiased
i know to begin with yeah it's like
driving a car your whole life and then
realizing that like in the u.s people
have four wheels on their car and you're
like what
yeah like i thought it was specifically
like a blank spot on my car with that
but the wheel goes there it's like no
way
it's like yeah
yeah it's like exactly and then that's
right it's that that further discredits
the enterprise
in in where they want it to be like
totally totally aged
no but that is the point that that you
know like and that is the counterpoint
which is you know oh if they'll just
build their own but it's like it's not
about like that kind of market
like capital so to speak of like how how
big
is your like audience or how big is your
data or whatever it's like
it's like no it's like that's one of the
problems with capitalism you're making a
product people it allows and like what
what should it be known for and what
does it stand by like what is that
product's reputation if google's
reputation is
it depends on what i mean like not even
just location based like
like if you search for auto mechanics in
alabama you'll get auto mechanics from
alabama but like from a geographical
standpoint if you go country to country
and we'll get
results that are skewed yeah we'll
probably of someone's agenda
yeah screw that is that is so completely
unacceptable
it's so gross it's so gross and that's
why yeah i don't know so hopefully the
russians can have their own revolution
thankfully the us dealt with ours you
know we had that one 300 years ago and
then another one kind of kind of and we
kind of actually then the other one that
was pretty significant yeah yeah but uh
so
not have another one of those i don't i
don't want i know we got that out of we
got that out of the way so far
russia i don't i don't think people
quite realize like especially our
generation and the generation that's
younger than us like
we've never seen
dead people in the street you know yeah
and like yeah your your your loved ones
and we haven't been very good you've
never seen you've never seen your entire
livelihood bankrupt by inflation
you know like these are real problems
that are starting to come back because
people are acting irresponsibly
and that's what's tragic about the
ukraine thing
not the ukraine but ukraine's thing
is they did they did that in 2014.
yeah they did it they got right they had
they had it there's russian-backed
separatists they started like a pseudo
uh like government takeover
everything went bonkers and they came
out of it with a democracy
yeah good for them and now
russia's just rolling back through going
okay
the whole like
black ops freaking psyops crap didn't
work let's just go in there with the
actual tanks this time and it's just
it's tragic seeing
seeing it actually work finally you know
like oh cool here's a government shift
that actually results in a positive
outcome we've been seeing
the ones that go wrong for so many
decades and they finally nailed it in
2014
or like they did it you know
above average job you can rate it
however you want but the point is is
that it effectively worked
they got a decent
semi mostly free
government you know
society out of it it didn't have a
dictator running their country yeah so
anyways uh
anyway so that was the segway that was
the question
well nico this really this really
digs in on
that first amendment question that we
were talking about oh my god see that's
why i brought this up that's why that's
why i brought it up with those circles
it really does circle back to that
because it then it's like oh well hey
listen they're a private company they
should be allowed to make those kind of
moral decisions there's a difference
between legal and moral and both apply
yes
and legal does not equal moral
no and frankly moral reigns supreme
but yes but
legal you you in an ideal world
you're legal
is supportive and derived from your
moral 100 percent
yep
that that like
one is one and the other is the other
yeah
though there i think there is a nuance
there oh boy we're getting uh i know we
got back up
why do you not want to talk about this
we can talk
hey here's the thing about dune remember
on in dune in the beginning the house of
tradies goes to arrakis and they're like
hey everyone
the good guy the good guys are in town
free water everyone gets water for free
no biggie i
i was like watching a clip again i'm
like wait a second like
how are you gonna make that work like
functionally from a like just from a
like a supply chain standpoint like
there's
almost no water on this planet and you
all just roll in saying free water it's
like what are you gonna just
go to kaladan fill up a spaceship with
water and then freaking have some
brainiac
hyperloop it and dump it out
anyways that happens all the time
people promise people promise free stuff
all the time and they can't actually
deliver on it
but then they move on from that because
all the stuff goes crazy but i was just
thinking at first like wait what was the
what was the like the
yeah what was the infrastructure plan
you guys had for this one because this
is kind of a tall
order
uh but i guess it's more of a character
beat to show that they're nice
anyways sorry that that was that's it
even if they can't just run it hey at
least they promised it right yeah
yeah set up
just you promising it to me proves to me
that you have a moral compass i know you
won't deliver i know you'll let me down
but at least at least you promised me
something you couldn't deliver on that
makes you a good person because
that's
i'm not actually interested in the in
the way that the world is and creating a
structure that's that's based on that i
just want to know how would it how could
it be how could it be yeah i hereby
decree that uh
i
want everyone to be happy
yeah and i think exactly being happy
people used to be sad
[Laughter]
here goes the nuance jake i told you i
wouldn't do it here it comes all right
let's go back trying
let's talk about it all right i'm just
going to drop this the nuance between
legal and moral legally said legal is
not always there to enforce the morals
there needs to be space to allow people
to have their own morals as long as
they're not harming or intruding upon
the rights of others
yeah i don't disagree with that and and
that that that space allows for the
evolution of the law too yeah but
sometimes people see that as being
immoral because they they're like why
doesn't the law make you donate to
charity why doesn't the law make you do
community service why doesn't the law
someone who says that doesn't have very
much experience with understanding how
laws are executed
i think that's what that comes down to
but that's the ideal world thing that's
the like people should donate to charity
so why don't we make them
it's like
whoa
there's a big difference there
yeah
yeah yeah all right let's end let's end
on a let's say not a non-geopolitical
note um so
so last week uh
for our netflix youtube punch for punch
series
um
i got to do a fight scene i got to do a
real
karate fight scene with martial arts
gee and travis and a bunch of other
stunt people what guided me through it
and it was really fun
i did not realize how much you need to
be able to hit your poses in between the
hits and the blocks
you know it's like it's about the
chambering of your hits i didn't realize
how much goes into like needing to have
the rhythm figured out
um
but you know what i did okay but i did i
did mention this one feeling that i get
so it's like
you show up right
you're surrounded by experts who have
done this their entire lives it is their
life's pursuit and here you are saying i
want to learn how to do this in a day
it's a cool youtube video it feels kind
of disrespectful
and very posery for me to come in and
say that and so pardon me feels like a
little embarrassed by that i guess so
but i mean yeah if you're thinking about
it like the japanese like sushi chef
kind of
line of thinking yeah it's like you need
to what is it you have to clean their
underwear for 10 years or something
before you can even
like stand on a mat
like sure
but i don't know it's not once again
it's also not quite that too it's not
quite that it's not like you're just you
know random guy on the street you know
and that's the that's the setting that
gets people to be interested in the
episode but what it really is is an
opportunity to
just for you to learn and for them to
teach
that's really what it is that's true
though there is the other aspect
which is so then here's here's me here's
a guy
who does not quite know what he's doing
but he's trying really hard
and he's taking it really seriously
let's watch him just do his best
and just like barbie's like
no it's fine like it's not like i said
seeing you guys shot makes you look cool
hopefully i look cool thankfully you
have years of experience filming fight
sequences and talking with these people
in a similar industry
and like being involved on a very
intimate deep level you know you've gone
through this stuff that's true all
that's happening is your feet are just
moving from behind the camera to in
front of it you're making me feel better
and you're right we've done like i heard
you you've been watching it you've been
critiquing it you've been like all sorts
of stuff so it's all you don't know what
you're talking about it's like
i hear what you're saying it's like
that's like when i talk with logan about
hunting
right like from black rifle coffee who's
like logan has hunted like
in every environment you know he does
these like seven day like pack out hunts
where you're you're hunting mule deer
and you have to sneak up on them from
200 yards away and be completely silent
and then like be covered in camouflage
and like you know it's like this crazy
experience that i
have never done
but i know like i you know it's like
yeah i've hunted yeah you get i get it
you put the things in your head
and
he's like and it's like no but the
difference between like his experience
and mine
like i feel like an imposter when i talk
to him about that stuff because it's
like
it's i'll never get it until i do it you
know yeah that's fine yeah i just got to
pretend
no but it's not about pretending it's
not about like it's not about pretending
it's also like
you know it's just you being there in
that environment with those guys like
appreciating it and learning from them
and taking part in it earnestly
is respectful
right that's true
that's true and that's that's respectful
of their craft and like they appreciate
that i'm sure and they're not looking at
it like oh man you know
nico and nico and jake and sam brought
me in on this damn show to like teach
nico how to be a stunt man
you know they're not like an idiot yeah
they're they're like pumped about it and
there's
an opportunity for them to share and to
be part of some of the thing where they
get to
you know continue to to show off what
the art is that that's true true
true i guess somebody goes like oh look
at this dumb youtuber trying to do a
fight scene it's like whatever i guess
it's more views there's always going to
be some bitter prick who says that i
mean yeah yeah you just can't take much
time to regard it
yeah
yeah
well
i guess i'll
i guess i'll go home eat dinner let's
film another one
let's let's film another one
we got three more episodes to go so
let's do it yeah heck yeah
well we're gonna be doing the sword
fights next
yeah i'm amped about that i'm happy
about that one too
so we're doing like i'm all like it's
witcher themed but like i'm all into
elder elden ring right now so i'm like
all right let's go like elden ring grit
on these on these knights and
vagabonds what kind of sword are you
gonna use well so it's i don't know
what's sorted but it's gonna be the the
story that little mini story currently
is that ghee is playing basically like
a wandering mercenary night and he comes
up against like three rich noble like
noblemen assassins is gonna be a
nobleman assassin no i'm not in
it so you don't have to certify that one
no i don't find that one i will
theoretically be taking a wire pull
through a wall at some point you're
gonna do that can you please set up like
the most
not like the unexpected situation for
that to happen though
the least
likely situation to be pulled
that got pulled through a wall uh on
like
some major picture and
was it luke
no i can't remember lucas pulled through
walls
i think
maybe he was telling a story he's always
telling a story maybe it was somebody he
was telling a story about i don't know
but just be careful be careful man
getting pulled through walls is no joke
100 well i've gone through drywall
before so as long as we're just doing
one panel drywall and it's like oh
yeah well that's not gonna look that
cool though you're gonna need to go oh
okay fine and some bricks
yeah oh gosh you gotta go through more
than a single day you prefer the
comments
here's jake like look at this dumb dude
that's like the inner piece
i'm gonna
thank you thank you
all right thanks for listening to our
podcast everybody um
[Music]
yeah
it was fun i like talking about cool
things with my buddies
so
consider subscribing and uh yeah that's
the best thing about the world these
days despite all the darkness
[Music]
is
there's cool things still happening
somewhere every week that's true
that's right
all right thanks for watching peace out
bye
[Music]